wonderful to be back here at Yale
remembering when I saw
hannoush here
out of human rights investigation in
Zimbabwe and that was a that was a tough
ride here I've just come from Baltimore
so a little bit easier what I'm going to
talk with you about today is this really
very unfortunate reality that globally
and in the United States the HIV
epidemics among men have sex with men
gay and bisexual men really are on a
very different trajectory from the rest
of global aids and the reasons for that
are complex I think they're important
and interesting from an epidemiologic
perspective and I think inform what what
we need to do for the future and I'm
going to I'm going to talk as we go
through this about the epidemiology
about the burden and risks about some
stochastic models that I think will help
explain some of our thinking about these
epidemics a little bit about the
disparities with african-american MSM
but also black MSM and Canada in the UK
because I think that those sub X which
are so severe really help explain the
bigger picture and then we'll talk about
prevention and care responses and then
finally I want to end talking about the
human rights components of this because
both in the US but certainly in so many
countries we are not going to get much
further with HIV prevention treatment
and care without advancing human rights
agenda for sexual minorities I think
that is very fundamental let me just say
before I jump into this talk that most
of what I'm going to be presenting to
you today not all but much of it comes
from work we have done over the last two
years for a special issue of The Lancet
which I guest edited with several
colleagues ken Maher from Harvard
Patrick Sullivan from Emory Jorge
Sanchez from impact and Peru and for
which we had a number of really
spectacular lead authors Patrick
Sullivan led the prevention work you're
going to see Gregorio Mallette CDC in
the White House I did the work on black
MSM I led the epidemiology invest
and then the modeling was done by a
colleague Steve Goudreau University of
Washington so just want to acknowledge
all of them up front and to say that
this is really work that builds on those
two years so let's start off with the
burden of disease and I think I like to
start sometimes with the take home these
are the take homes for this burden of
disease exercise and basically what we
see is that these epidemics are still
expanding by which I mean there are
still wherever we have incidence data
there really are rising rates of new
infection in high and low income
countries and these epidemics are really
marked by consistently by high burdens
and young men rapid spread clustering
within networks of MSM that's going to
be a very important part of trying to
understand these epidemics high
frequency of dual and multiple
transmitted HIV variants its molecular
evidence that really describes the
epidemiology I'm not going to go into
the molecular epi in the interest of
time but it is in The Lancet paper that
you'll be seeing some data from and they
appear to be driven by hyper act and /
partner HIV transmission probabilities
by the sexual versatility of men with in
sexual networks which turns out to be a
very important component of this and by
network and structural level risks that
will get into the methods for this work
is basically comprehensive reviews of
all the available data globally from
2007 through the end of 2011 systematic
reviews of molecular epi and then this
modeling exercise using a stochastic
agent-based model oh good I was just
about to say I hope you can see that but
it's quite clear here so this is the
summary data by region of all of the
available HIV prevalence data these are
pooled adjusted levels and what you're
looking at here is in purple is the HIV
prevalence from the best available un
aids Global Fund data for reproductive
age adults by region and then the rate
in MSM in the same regions
right so there is remarkable consistency
here wherever you look this is
sub-saharan Africa of course the highest
burden of disease in all populations but
also an extraordinarily high burden in
MSM these are the ninety-five percent
confidence intervals around these
estimates so even though the data are
spotty and in some areas like the Middle
East and North Africa the confidence
intervals are quite wide they never
approach anywhere near equity with the
general population samples this is East
Asia with quite low general population
prevalence but still high epidemic and
this unfortunately is the Caribbean a
region with relatively high rates and
heterosexuals but as you can see an
extraordinarily severe epidemic in MSM
this is what it looks like when you put
essentially the same data on a global
map but now looking at prevalence
estimates these are pooled prevalence
estimates adjusted for size the red
color is over fifteen percent prevalence
so those are the highest burdens of
prevalent disease you can see
unfortunately that that includes the
u.s. a number of countries in southern
Eastern and West Africa pretty much all
of the contiguous countries in Southeast
Asia but as you can see high burdens
globally now these are the available
incidence data through the end of last
year there is much less of this all
together I think we have something like
15 countries represented about 20 or so
populations these very high outliers are
available data on Kenya there is one
incidence point for the whole of Africa
extraordinarily high burden and the same
emerging from China this slide now needs
to be updated because just this week
there was incidence data from the
Bangkok cohort the mo pH CDC and that
unfortunately also shows very high
incidence
indeed but it's a very incomplete map
this is from the call to action paper at
the end of this series and what you're
looking at here in blue is where there's
available data and in white is countries
that have never done an incident
assessment now it is 30 years into the
HIV pandemic and at the beginning it was
known that this was an extraordinarily
high burden disease in men have sex with
men so still a long ways to go and you
can see for yourselves where the
clustering of really the complete
absence of data is so what about risks
for HIV infection well the individual
level risks well-characterized I won't
go into those here but suffice to say
that they are increasingly insufficient
to explain this extraordinary divergence
in epidemiology the network level risks
have been looked at and those it turns
out really are very important MSM
networks tend to be larger than for
other sexual groups they are lower
density those findings have been found
in MSM networks in China and Australia
and among racial and ethnic minority men
in the US and then of course there are
structural risks that are really very
different and we will save some time to
go into this near the end but there is
emerging data that structural factors
like criminis a shin of same-sex
behavior between consenting adults
stigma enacted discrimination in health
care settings i'll show you some data
from africa on that issues like
blackmail and fear of disclosure
continue to really be structural
barriers to access to services for these
men so what about the biology the
biological factors turn out to be
incredibly important in understanding
these epidemics is this mic working for
people can you hear me okay so first and
foremost is a reality that has nothing
to do with being gay but has to do with
the colon which is that the per act
transmission probability in anal sex
irregardless of the gender of the
receptive partner is just much much
higher than for
vaginal sex the best estimate and this
is from the Bagley modeling that has
recently been updated is 1.4 per act
transmission probability and unprotected
anal intercourse that is 18 times the
biological transmissibility or
probability for vaginal sex so that is
hugely determinative and again that is
the same regardless of the gender of the
receptive partner over time that leads
to a forty percent per partner
probability for couples who practice
this behavior so that again is an
extraordinarily high per pack
transmission probability the usual
numbers that people use for vaginal
intercourse anybody know the per act
transmission probability about one in a
thousand right so really markedly lower
and then of course there's the reality
of what we are calling here sex-role
versatility so you're all adults
everybody knows that in heterosexual sex
the insertive and receptive partners are
biologically determined right you with
me all right good now but with men that
is not the case right there you can be
both the insertive in the receptive
partner in the same partnership in the
same evening and of course within wider
networks that turns out to dramatically
increase the transmission efficiency of
HIV at network levels right it's a very
important parameter so we wanted to take
these biological structural risks the
behavioral risks and try and think about
this in some innovative ways to get a
handle on the dynamics driving these
epidemics and to do that agent-based
stochastic modeling has proven to be a
really a powerful tool and Steve
Goudreau who's working with some of your
colleagues here is a tremendous modeler
University of Washington so we enlisted
him and my former Hopkins colleague and
friend Ron brookmire to work with us on
this model and this again is in Lancet
paper and we started with a
counterfactual experiment right so
here's how the experiment works you say
if anal sex were as infectious as
vaginal sex so we're going to
parameterize a model we actually promote
it for urban and rural us and urban and
rural Peru populations of MSM and let's
just say that the transmission
probability isn't any different how much
smaller would the HIV epidemic be if we
just change that everything else stays
the same the numbers of partners the
numbers of guys who are using substances
the number of people who have extra
primary relationship partners the number
of people who pay for sex or are paid
for it the STI burden everything else
and happily this all this data was
parameterised for the Puma prevention
umbrella in the Americas trial that
Susan buchbinder is leading so we
already had all that work done in
advance so i won't get into all the
details but just suffice to say that
this is a very well parameterised model
and it really does accurately describe
the epidemics the idea is that you
create a idealized population we're
using an N here of 5,000 men we started
with an HIV prevalence of fifteen
percent because that unfortunately is
where the usm Peru both are in MSM
epidemics and we're looking now going
forward at a five-year incidence
projection so here is what you see and
here's my pointer this is the five-year
reduction in incidents over time and if
all we do and you're looking at urban us
in blue urban Peru and red and these are
urban us and Peru with adding high
levels of testing and treatment so a
third of the men who need HIV testing
and treatment or on it so we again tried
to model this based on an optimistic
scenario in fact unfortunately it's
about twenty two percent of us
populations actually have those levels
of care and it's lower for MSM so this
is a slightly better scenario you don't
have to worry too much because of course
the findings suggest that all these
scenarios matter very little if you
change the infective
anal sex to that of vaginal sex eighty
percent of the MSM epidemics go away
that starts to look a great deal like
heterosexual transmission in those same
populations now this is what happens if
you play around with role segregation
and the idea here is to say in this
population of 5,000 men half the men are
going to be inserted half are going to
be receptive and nobody switches roles
so that again is like a heterosexual
epidemic setting and what you see is
that you actually do get some changes
you get reductions of up to perhaps half
the population lower in for example in a
Peru because there already is more
sexual segregation among MSM in those
settings this we really just did as as a
standalone because obviously nobody is
going to change their behaviors in those
ways it's just an exercise but when we
put those two parameters together so
vaginal infectivity and roll segregation
you now are basically modeling what HIV
looks like in a network of heterosexuals
and basically the epidemic goes away
that tail which ranges between about two
percent and perhaps eight percent of
transmission is what is explained by
behavioral differences right and of
course that has been the enormous focus
of our interventions okay so just to
summarize this and I've gone through it
in some detail the transmission
probabilities play a huge role the role
versatility plays a very important role
and it can explain about between fifteen
or twenty and fifty five percent or so
of the epidemic I didn't get into the
stable partnerships but reducing
unprotected anal intercourse and stable
partnerships also had some impact but
relatively modest so what does that say
I think what it says is that we need
preventive interventions that can reduce
infectiousness and that can reduce the
probability of acquisition and
unprotected sex so just hold on to that
when we get to the prevention
or we'll talk about what those might be
now sorry my to close pull it away is
that better sorry so now if you look at
the sub epidemic among black MSM and the
related health disparities I think what
I've just taken you through starts to
appear more clearly and I think this
helps us understand what's going on so
here you're looking this is data from
the CDC on young MSM in the United
States age 13 to 24 rising but rising
relatively slowly in white and Hispanic
young men this is african-americans
completely different trajectory now
these are this is a beautiful a
systematic review and meta-analysis by
Greg millet and colleagues in Lancet
series and essentially what you're
looking at here these are odds ratios
across the bottom the the line for unity
unfortunately is not appearing very
clearly in this but it's here you could
see it this is one so everything to the
left of this is lower risks and
essentially what you see is that this is
comparing black to other MSM is that in
terms of discordant unprotected anal
intercourse partners black men have
fewer they have lower numbers of sex
partners they have less receptive anal
intercourse and they have markedly
higher HIV rates so it's very
counterintuitive finding for comparison
they also looked at black versus other
racial and ethnic minority or majority
MSM in the UK where there's better
universal health insurance but actually
the same pattern holds although the
rates are markedly lower this is an
analysis again from greg's group looking
at structural level experiences and
resiliency comparing us black MSM to
other MSM and here you have HIV
prevalence these are summary odds lower
education markedly higher rates in black
MSM of HIV lower income ever
incarcerated an important factor
unemployment still giving you an odds
ratio of about 1.5 any structural
barrier over two over twice as likely to
be HIV positive but happily any
resilient behavior also markedly better
for black MSM so the structural barriers
really are important sorry and when he
put this together and looked at the
famous treatment cascade here again
you're looking at disparities between
black and white MSM in the United States
across this treatment cascade what you
see is that black men are much more
likely to have undiagnosed HIV that's a
6 up there for those of you who can't
see it about six times as likely to have
undiagnosed HIV about two and a half
times as likely to happen to be HIV
positive markedly lower levels of health
insurance coverage of a RT utilization
and access of starting cd4s of starting
a Arby's above 200 which we of course
would like to see much lower rates a RT
adherence is a bit lower and the bottom
line for HIV suppression is that they of
course are much less likely to have
suppressed HIV infection now if you
think about the effect of treatment on
prevention and the network issues that
we looked at before what you are seeing
here is a much greater likelihood of
untested and untreated HIV now he's
added the structural barriers to this
health insurance coverage lower income
which moves across all of these and
healthcare access which is also markedly
lower and I think we begin to get a
handle on why that epidemic is so much
more severe so what are we going to do
about it well this is Patrick Sullivan's
very elegant work looking at enervate
interventions efficacy and evidence and
what you have here is behavioral
interventions basically in blue
biomedical in green the one structural
one we have in this brown color the size
of the ball is about the strength of the
evidence so we have very strong evidence
but unfortunately we're starting here
with the lowest efficacy
the biomedical interventions have weaker
evidence because most of them are
relatively small trials in the case of
prep for example just one trial but
their efficacy is higher and of course
the highest efficacy is for antiviral
therapy but that has been evaluated in
discordant couples not yet in MSM
there's also tremendous bias if you look
globally in where these data come from
and what we know about effective
interventions so this is a global
summary map the size of the ball here is
about the the size of the populations
that are participated in these studies
what you can see for example is the
purple are below 100 MSM so they've been
a bunch of trials but with very small
numbers of men and as you can see most
of what we know is from the US and
obviously it's a big diverse world now
here again Steve Goudreau was the
modeler looking at modeling prevention
impacts again agent-based stochastic
using several countries and this time
using original data from Kenya and India
to add to the US and Peru and really
looking at the three preventive
interventions that from the literature
suggests would be the most likely to
have an impact here prep treatment of
positives and increasing condom use
through condom promotion and lube and
doing that at community level because as
better evidence for the efficacy of that
that at individual levels and now
looking at outcomes over ten years and
what you can see is that prep has some
ability across all of these countries to
reduce HIV incidence and this by the way
is is set at about forty percent
adherence and prep that of course is
based on the I prex trial the first
trial we have of evidence for efficacy
with prep this is early antivirals and
again it's forty percent coverage of
early treatment for HIV and a very
disappointing outcome in fact we thought
that that would have a bigger impact we
can talk about why that might be and
then condom promotion which varies
across countries and obviously has the
biggest impact in a place like India
wear condoms and appropriate lubes
actually are a challenge for people this
is looking at and maybe just in the
interest of time I won't go into it into
too much detail but this is the MSM
infections averted by early antiviral
therapy looking at coverage levels and
we're tried to see in this exercise if
coverage got a lot better could we bump
up the impact of antivirals for MSM
these again are the same for countries
that you're looking at the u.s. Peru
Kenya and India and what you can see is
even when you get into very high
coverage levels sixty to eighty percent
we're still not getting over a third of
infections of burden and that I think is
a real challenge for thinking about the
impact of treatment as prevention for
this population these are prep data
doing the same thing trying to get up to
extraordinarily high levels of prep
ninety percent in the green across these
countries and best case scenario about a
thirty five percent reduction over 10
years in new HIV infections so each of
these in and of themselves is not going
to get us there okay don't be depressed
but it just means that there is a great
deal of work to do in this field if
we're really going to turn this around
but obviously there are other threats to
prevention and it's not just that we
don't have the strongest technologies
there also are tremendous forms of
stigma homophobia and Prejudice out
there there's threats of violence and
very real forms of violence there's a
huge lack of training of healthcare
workers particularly in developing
countries with any expertise in
providing services to these populations
there's criminalization in a number of
countries sometimes with quite severe
penalties many of you know that Uganda
is debating a death penalty bill for
homosexuality that has gotten out of
committee may be passed and there are of
course technical challenges to putting
together prevention packages and trying
to get those out there this is work that
we did in Namibia Botswana and Malawi
looking at the impact of health care
level discrimination
access to care for men who have sex with
men former graduate student of ours
Heather Fey and I'll just just show you
for example that when we look at men
diagnosed with an STI or treated ever
tested for HIV men who reported a self
diagnosis if you look at things like
fear of seeking healthcare it's an
extraordinarily common behavior or
anxiety actually being denied health
care services because of being gay was
was a experience of about seven times
more likely for men who had an STI much
more likely for men who were diagnosed
with an STI extraordinarily commonly
reported by men who reported themselves
being HIV positive and when we looked at
this blackmail parameter blackmail by
the way it came out of our qualitative
work for those of you who do qualitative
work it is still vitally important to do
that we asked men what their issues were
and this kept coming up we didn't really
understand it at first but basically the
way it operates is if people disclose
their sexual orientation then health
care providers insist on money or they
will disclose that to other people right
so obviously if you know that that's
going to happen or if a clinic gets a
reputation for that it kind of inhibits
people's willingness to talk openly
right so that's what we're looking at
and just for example anybody who told
that they needed an HIV test almost
twice as likely to report having been
blackmailed men who self-reported they
were HIV positive about five times as
likely and that really is you know just
very fundamental to why provision of
services for this population remains
such a challenge this is from the
newspaper in Uganda more homos faces
exposed and what this Rolling Stone
paper has been doing is listing the
names and home addresses of gay men
right and getting people killed so what
can we say about prevention for this
population our historical approaches
individual-level behavioral
interventions really are not working
best-case scenario with our modeling
is that with the tools we have today we
think we can reduce 25% of new
infections in MSM over the next 10 years
that's good it's important it's a great
goal it's not the finish line right and
maximizing preventive interventions is
going to include some smart prevention
packages but really also structural
interventions right and by that we mean
dealing with some of these sexual
minority human rights issues so you know
gay men their allies LGBT populations
have been fighting a human rights fight
around HIV since the beginning right
these are some images from act up great
graphics from aids demographics this is
david kato the Ugandan leader who was
murdered this has been a long-standing
fight and it's not over it's remarkable
actually when you look when we modeled
and then did a cost estimate around that
condom and lube provision worldwide the
price tag is about a hundred and thirty
four million dollars sound like a lot of
money right I mean actually it's cheap
but it's not happening and a lot of the
reason it's not happening is homophobia
now when we think about clinical care
and clinical care interventions this is
going to be a huge part of the future
and what needs to happen because right
now in so many of these settings men are
being excluded or exclude themselves
from care because of their sexual
orientation and in this country you know
thanks to the survival of the Affordable
Care Act we're going to extend health
care to 37 million Americans depending
on which states agree and go along and
many of those folks are indeed people at
risk young LGBT folks and they are going
to be challenging to our health care
system as well as they come into it the
US has changed its policies poor
Condoleezza Rice had the job during the
Bush administration of standing up and
saying we stand with Iran in opposing
human rights for LGBT populations that
has changed this is a direct quote from
Hillary
Quentin at the UN Human Rights
Commission in Geneva and for those of
you who remember her famous you know
formulation in Beijing women's rights or
human rights and human rights her
women's rights she echoed that with this
right gay rights her human rights and
human rights are gay rights could I have
a round of applause for them well
Hillary Clinton yeah and i must say that
Secretary Clinton is giving this morning
her last major aids policy speech can't
wait to see it on youtube and suggest
you all do too she's going to lay out
the blueprint for an aids-free
generation and she is going to focus on
key populations including msn so when we
looked at this in terms of what are the
human rights principles and and treaties
and so forth that are out there in
support of inclusion of sexual
minorities in HIV care and services
really it's hard to do better than the
yoga Carter principles and for those of
you who are not familiar with these this
was an attempt by a distinguished group
of international jurists to go through
all existing human rights law and
through the lens of which of the
elements of it really spoke to LGBT
rights and I will just highlight for you
that that several of these rights
domains that we thought were
particularly relevant for addressing
human rights for sexual minorities first
of call of course is that universal most
of the Human Rights documents are indeed
universal and they spell out at the
beginning that all human beings are
entitled to these rights so unless you
take the position that some governments
do that homosexuals are not human beings
there is really a universal basis here
the second is the highest attainable
standard of health again you know
reiterated through a number of
conventions and treaties and very much
strongly supporting that everybody has a
right to the highest attainable standard
of health and certainly for MSM that's
critical one protection from medical
abuses is in a number of Human Rights
treaties and of course exclusion based
on sexual orientation or gender identity
is a medical abuse right blackmail is in
medical abuse so that one really matters
and then interestingly particularly now
as as we are entering the era of the
struggle for marriage equality the right
to found a family is a fundamental human
right and one that certainly relates to
our concerns of course if you want to
talk about human rights and get into the
the cultural social religious challenges
we face there's no better religious
leader on this issue I think
particularly in Africa then Archbishop
Desmond Tutu so we asked him to provide
a comment for the last paper in this
Lancet series which he did and which
I'll read to in a moment but I'll just
say that when this whole series went
live and we had the International
Conference so many people were there we
thought everybody was going to be
excited about our stochastic agent
ribbon modeling you know isn't that this
the best part you know but in fact the
quotes from 22 are what went viral all
right and it went viral first of all
because he's such a recognizable voice
but also because very deliberately right
we asked him to speak to these
fundamental issues and we particularly
wanted him to address the youth issue
because of course you know all the data
suggests that young sexual minority
folks are such high risk for the LGBT
youth out there who are struggling who
are made to feel inferior let me say
this God loves you as you are he wants
you to live and thrive so please take
care of yourself educate yourself about
HIV protect your partner's honor and
cherish them and never let anyone make
you feel inferior for being who you are
when you live the life you were meant to
live in freedom and dignity you put a
smile on God's face
he should always have the last word in
my view I just want to end by thanking
so many of my colleagues students
funders who supported this work the
epidemiology paper was a very
distinguished group of colleagues
including Stemper all in our group at
Hopkins fritzman greens and Steve
Goudreau and Ron brookmire you can see
the black MSM authors that Greg led the
prevention paper included alex caballo
diaz and tom cote Steve Goudreau again
Jorge Sanchez and this call to action
paper all the lead authors for the
series but then several other folks who
agreed to participate with us and I
would just point out le queda birra who
is a Ugandan physician and was president
of the International AIDS Society
immediately agreed to sign on and helped
us with this and that particularly in
the context of Uganda is a real act of
courage which we appreciate this work
was supported by amfar and by the Bill
and Melinda Gates Foundation and also by
the Hopkins see far